the one thing i'm most fascinated about
is this time that you spent as an exotic
dancer you were a male
dancer yeah i guess you could have tom
morello come to your bachelorette party
you still can because of covid uh tom
isn't working as a musician
yeah she's sitting at home only via zoom
now but i will tell you
rates have gone up considerably i'm
fascinated by this my roommate and i
at the time had aspirations to we had a
like a
a one-room apartment in hollywood and
we to and enhance our dating lives we
thought that the thing that would help
would be is if we had a hot tub
in our living room and so we could of
course couldn't afford a hot tub it was
hot
but we so we so we figured out how much
money was going to take to buy
a like this indoor kiddie pool and a
water heater and this that and the other
to sort of simulate
and then we worked towards that with
this extracurricular activity
can you imagine poor women walking into
your apartment seeing a baby pool
maybe not i mean like look it might not
have been the greatest it didn't first
of all
having a having a three and a half foot
tall 10 foot diameter 101 degree
roommate is a horrible roommate
but you would dance on stage and would
women like uh there wasn't it was like
it was a bachelorette party
i see it so wow that that so you knock
at the door like you're wearing a suit
you knock at the door
ask for a cup of sugar brick house comes
on the stereo it wasn't awesome i got to
tell you
it wasn't awesome it really wasn't it
was it wasn't you didn't like it it was
weird no
i didn't like it didn't last long it
didn't work we're just trying to make a
certain amount of money to get that
horrible hot tub in our place
what a goal and then we were retired i
remember when rage went on stage
nude it was a protest yes you guys stood
there
for 15 minutes yeah the pmrc you were
protesting this movement to censor rock
music and the band decided
we're not going to [ __ ] play we're
going to stand up there
naked did everyone in the band agree to
this because they all
did rage all have big penises
it's funny because like we've we're
pretty deep in the interview before we
got to that i'm like i knew eventually
we could
but it is an important point sometimes
sometimes you gotta you know you gotta
suffer for your art howard
no one said no in the band no no one in
the band said look man
there was there is a discussion there
was a discussion about it and you know
it was a time
that uh you know i just thought we all
thought we all this was something that
we
had talked about a couple of cities
beforehand but the re the the irony of
that day was it was like the day this
was in philly so it was like it was the
closest show to new york city at the
time and this was the day when the
record company
sent everybody down to the show like
this is
rage against the hottest new band on
lollapalooza
you're gonna see them in all their glory
and and we didn't even play
it was like a 15 minute feedback
protest of nudity you know and then we
left the stage and i remember talking
with like the
one of the record execs afterwards and
he was like thanks a lot for that i'm
like hey man if you sign a band
name rage against the machine you get
rage against the machine my penis
honestly is the size of your guitar pick
and i am not going naked
no i am against the pmr theme again what
the cause is how
i don't care what there's no cause great
enough there's no
there's no cause great enough for me to
get naked
you